THE
OPENING
SHOT FROM THE POINT, RIGHT ON.
BATTED BACK BY FOX. TO BANK IT
IN.
IT WAS ONE OF THE TOUGHEST JOBSS
FOR SOMEBODY TO STAY READY WHE.
DO NOW, HE MINDS THREE.TWO FOR E
MOMENT.
NASH RIGHT ON TO BE THAT FOURTHF
MIDAIR.
HEDMAN FOR KUCHEROV. PERRY WITHG
CHANCE.
HEDMAN PASS
ACROSS TO
NOW, THE RANGERS HAVE TO MAKE
FRONT.
AND IT WAS OF ROOF
COVE -- KUCHEROV A A
KUCHEROV HAD A SHOT IN GAME
THREE.
HIM AND KUCHEROV
KEEPS HIS ROLL GOING, FRONT.
IN TRAFFIC THE RUTTA TRAILING
HIM. AID.
PANARIN BANKS IT TO THE FAR
LITTLE GIVE-AND-GO THIS SHOT
HITS THE RIGHT A THE NET.
PALAT SENDS AWAY FROM PICKING
UP LATE IN THE SECOND
WITHOUT CHYTIL.
RAY: YEA
LINDGREN TAKE PUCK OVER ON THERR
TAMPA WORKINGS BELLEMARE.
AND NOWHE POWER PLAY, PUTS IT
RIGHT IN THE CREASE.
NET.
RUTTA HAS TWO ASSISTS IN CONCH
LIKE THIS A FEW TIMES.
DEFLECTION OF THE SHOT. FEET OFO
ANIP.
VASILEVSKIY TURNS THAT ASIDE AND
AS THE IF YOU CAN BOUNCES OFF OF
THREE, BROKE A 2-2 TIE.
HIS SOUTH CAREER GAME-WINNNN